in a perfect world every awesome
videogame idea would become a reality
but our world isn't perfect and many
surefire hit games never make it past
the beta stage it's a shame to lose out
on the copious amounts of sheer fun many
of these games would generate it so
let's sit through the scrapyard of
canceled games and pick out some buried
treasures whoa nice graphics I'd like to
get my hands on that game Gotham by
Gaslight Batman plus anything usually
equals success well almost anything
based on the comic book of the same name
Gotham by Gaslight would have been no
different players took control of
steampunk Batman roaming Victorian
England in search of Jack the Ripper why
Jack because after dealing with the
Joker for so long it's sometimes good to
relax with an easier foe sadly day one
Studios the company behind Gotham by
Gaslight was unable to sell publisher
THQ on a free roaming Batman game where
Bruce goes toe to toe with one of the
most infamous killers in history
guess like Batman lives on in Lego
Batman 3 beyond Gotham arkham origins
and Infinite Crisis among others all of
which let you play as the Victorian era
Dark Knight to your heart's desire
highlander games based on TV shows and
movies are hit or miss to say the least
but highlander looked like it would have
been a hit your exploits as an immortal
would have sent you throughout history
to locales like ancient Rome Pompeii and
New York City kind of like playing all
the Assassin's Creed games at once - the
crappy sequels you'd also get to perform
all sorts of cool death-defying stunts
like leaping down skyscrapers or
electrocuting yourself without actually
dying
they even had an actual writer from the
Highlander TV series to write the
project sadly square-enix themselves did
the butchering canceling the game in
2010 for unknown reasons the studio was
probably too busy dragging its feet with
the next Final Fantasy or Kingdom Hearts
to set aside a weekend and just finished
Highlander already high ten Bomberman if
you enjoy mindless party games as much
as you love fiery explosions high ten
Bomberman would have been your jam it
was going to be a regular Bomberman on
steroids allowing up to 10 people to
play at once either against each other
in groups or if anyone's feeling
particularly sadistic 9 versus one more
bombers more bombs more explosions who
could ask for anything more
unfortunately high ten Bomberman never
went anywhere aside from a few Japanese
conventions in 1993 now that we have
ultra-hd an online multi-player why not
give it another go in a society that
still actively enjoys turning each other
into crispy critters high 10 Bomberman
would have been a smash hit today BC in
intrepid Computer Entertainment BC you
control a tribe of Neanderthals on a
quest to kill anyone not on your tribe
thereby evolving the human race in your
image along the way you have to battle
Angry apes and gigantic man-eating
dinosaurs both of whom hate everything
about you except your rich meaty flavor
sadly BC was simply too ambitious plan
features included changing weather and
epic food chain independently
functioning NPCs and the ability to
choose who to let into your tribe the
project was canceled in 2004 but in the
modern gaming scene BC would fit right
in and likely be among the best insane
lots of us love survival horror games so
imagine somebody who truly knows horror
giving it a shot
this would have been the case with
insane a 2012 game directed by Guillermo
del Toro of Hellboy and Pan's Labyrinth
fan insane was to be the most terrifying
sandbox game of all time Plus del Toro
had an entire trilogy in mind financial
difficulties forced THQ to focus solely
on guaranteed hits however rather than
experimental horror projects currently
del Toro owns all the rights to insane
so if he could always make it a reality
with another game company or simply turn
it into a badass movie franchise
provided he's not too busy explaining
why hull boy 3 still isn't happening
silent hill's
another abandoned guillermo del toro
project silent hill's was supposed to be
the director's collaboration with Metal
Gear series creator Hideo Kojima add The
Walking Dead's Norman Reedus and you've
had a guaranteed win this trifecta of
legendary figures would have made for an
incredible psychological horror
experience in the ps4 but it was sad to
cancel rumors had at the Kojima was
leaving Konami which was why the project
was pulled PT the playable teaser for
the game was pulled from the PlayStation
Store as well but you can still relive
the terror if you kept the demo in your
library sadly it's the closest you'll
ever get to silent hill's
Star Wars 1313 as a young Boba Fett Star
Wars 1313 would allow you to navigate
the wretched hive of scum and villainy
that is the underground Khorasan where
there are no Jedi to keep the peace 1313
focused almost entirely on guns blasters
and whatever else that bounty hunter
would need to get his dirty job done
unfortunately this amazing
that wouldn't survive the one thing more
evil in the dark side corporate
takeovers when Disney bought the Star
Wars franchise in 2012 it canceled
anything LucasArts had in the pipeline
including 1313 current Star Wars game
publisher EA has shown little interest
in 1313 preferring to focus on more
mainstream canonical games like
battlefront LucasArts meanwhile has
given us Angry Birds Star Wars 2 Star
Wars 1313 has left somewhere in the
junkyard likely near Luke Skywalker's
dismembered hand Megaman universe
Megaman is awesome that's pretty much
just science no would have been even
more awesome the ability to make your
own levels and customize your very own
Megaman just think Mario maker that was
the premise for Megaman universe a
side-scrolling platformer that was
supposed to be released on Xbox Live
Arcade and the PlayStation Network we
would love to have seen what kind of
sick twisted platforming gauntlets
creative players could have shared
online this game came to fruition and
even cooler was the fact that were you
from Street Fighter and Arthur from
ghosts and goblins were planned as DLC
characters sadly the game was cancelled
in 2011 so now we only have our super
fighting robot dreams to hang on to Star
Fox 2 releasing a direct sequel to the
original Star Fox in the Super Nintendo
would have been a no brainer but it
didn't work out that way
Star Fox 2 would have continued the
story and reassemble the original team
to fight Emperor and Ross and protect
the lylat system including new ships and
new characters unfortunately the arrival
of the Nintendo 64 stopped development
on the title although Japanese version 2
the prototype leaked online in 2015 it
might not have seen the light of day is
an official Super Nintendo game but Star
Fox 2 is alive out there somewhere and
we'd still love to bear all through it
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which lost games
you'd like to play